foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is done cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people
build well do work that they love create
actual amazing relationships
Jade warshaw newly minted Ramsey
personality is my co-host today already
vastly popular especially if you read
stuff like on the internet and things so
everybody loves Jade already the phone
number here will be talking to you Merry
Christmas America is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Autumn is
going to start off this hour St Louis
Missouri hi Autumn how are you hey hey
I'm good how
Jade what's going on
well I am sick and tired of being broken
normal and I have got all kinds of
scenarios running through my head I'm
hoping you guys can bring some clarity
on let's do it all right so uh my
husband and I started our debt-free
journey on November 4th we were 150 000
in debt overall we have been kicking
butt taking names so we're about 7 100
down including a thousand dollar
emergency fund and a fifteen hundred
dollar cash flow Christmas there you go
well yeah but it leaves us with 144 000
and half of that is a commercial loan
that we took out for a honey farm
um so here's the kicker I'm I mean I'm
good you know putting it in order doing
the BET snowball but I'm I feel like I'm
on a deadline so we've got our
commercial loan that's gonna balloon on
us on June of 2024.
so my husband wants to move to 72 000
above the the other that 144 includes
our mortgage so he wants to move it
above how much is your mortgage balance
51. okay that's not in the equation
that's baby step six
and uh what's your household income
uh about 110 to 115 on average
okay let's see so you got 90 grand
um and so we need to do 45 000 a year
for two years right right and you're
done before the balloon
well here's here's the other kicker this
is the other scenario and this is this
is where I'm hoping for the clarity so I
have worked for my job for about 19 and
a half years this June will make 20. and
it's been wonderful
um I will stick with it as long as I can
but
it's a small business and they could use
Dave so it is in danger and I also
homeschool my daughter so I work from
home so there's there's potentially
coming up a lull in my income which is
more than half of what I've said so what
do you do
um Jill of all trades girlfriend I mean
they they own a bunch of commercial
properties so anything and everything
that needs to be done from marketing to
accounting to everything
well I I am not going to make my
decisions based on something that might
happen they've been running this
business on a shoestring for years
they're probably going to continue to
run it on a shoestring
um unless you know something from doing
the books that's inside of there that's
that's recently more sick than other
things you've seen in the past I don't
think it changes anything because here's
the thing if you lose that job you got
to go get another one anyway right if
you don't if you if you feel like you're
insecure in that job there's nothing
that stops you today from starting to
look for something new so I don't think
you have to plan for a low in income I
think there's only going to be a low in
income if you see something coming and
you do nothing until it actually happens
I think right now if you feel like
you're insecure you can start looking
but um I'm with Dave I think that when
it comes to this debt we need to work
the debt snowball as usual of course the
51 000 that's your mortgage we can kind
of hold off on that side of it but it
sounds like all of this debt is kind of
it's not it doesn't sound like it's
separated business and personal it
sounds like you're on the hook for all
of it yeah there's no such thing as a
business loan in this setting right you
signed personally for every bit of this
debt it's all personal debt you just
labeled it business because it had to do
with the farm
so yeah let's roll it into that you got
70 000 in credit card debt you know I
mean let's get it paid off and you got a
balloon coming due in 24 so lay the
whole thing out to be done by 24. that
that's um you know was it June of 24.
just lay your game plan out go what have
we got to pay to be done I mean let's go
ahead and be done by March right uh so
we don't even don't want to run right up
on that balloon but uh this is very
doable very doable and the thing is the
whole process of being this intentional
and this intense is brand new and that's
when you have the most tendency to try
to scheme and scam your way through it
rather than work your way through it and
so quit trying to figure this out just
do it
I mean and do it with gusto even more
Gusto than you've done to this date get
after it and you can sell stuff you can
do all kinds of things if you have to
but and you can work out a different job
another job if this one starts to look
more and more and more weak like Jade
said go go land you something but let's
let's get this done Emily's in Santa
Barbara hi Emily welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey what's up
uh I have a question about what I should
do what me and my husband should do with
our year-end bonus uh because we're we
can't go exactly in the baby steps
because we already own the home we
bought it pre-days but besides that we
are debt free
the baby step the home home is in the
baby steps maybe step six
uh you're saying you bought a house
before it was time to in the baby steps
is it paid off
no okay then you have the regular baby
steps where are you in the baby steps
uh so that's paid off so uh with that
34k we can put 5K to finish our
emergency fund so we'll be at 20. so
you're debt-free but the house
yes okay and then you can finish your
emergency fund that's maybe step three
so what yeah so we'll finish it
emergency fund and then we want to put
uh max out both of our Ross 2022 so
that'd be 12. and then we're gonna put
um 2K for our each of our kids 529s we
have two kids good
um and then we have 15 left so that
would be a thousand per kid and then we
have 15. so we do have a truck that we
want to get up and running so we wanted
to see if that is okay it's an older
truck it's just a hobby it's classic old
old car uh or should we be throwing that
at the house no once you get past baby
step three you leave intensity and move
to intentional
okay and uh so if this is intentional
and you say okay we're gonna we're gonna
work on the hobby truck a little bit or
we need to buy a couch or we're going to
go on vacation or we need to buy a new
car because the one we got is a dumpy
one we got to move up a little that's
where this is where you would do all of
that knowing that every dollar you spend
there is not going towards your mortgage
so you're going to be in debt a little
longer but that's okay because it's
intentional versus intensity
okay but you don't do this with the
mindset of oh we're never going to get
our mortgage paid off
no we're gonna get our mortgage paid off
anyway
okay yeah that's really good I think a
lot of times when people start the baby
steps they get so focused on the on
being intense that when you get past
that phase it's kind of hard to leave
that mindset to the side and it's not to
say that you get lackadaisical but you
were never intended to live you know
under the gun for the entire I mean
you're supposed to enjoy some of this
money so it's about being intentional
about it you of your husband have
decided this is what we're gonna do this
is worth the opportunity cost and you've
made that decision together so you're
doing just right yep or it makes you
look and go I'd rather pay off my
mortgage than the truck so maybe it's
trying to get rid of the truck either
one's okay but now it's time to be
intentional not just intense so very
good question Merry Christmas to you
Emily this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Erica Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
uh we got deals out there right now Jade
uh in the store serious stuff going on
Financial Peace University gift voucher
as low as 69.99 Dr John delony's
best-selling book on your past change
your future uh deeply discounted at
12.99 the new Ramsay sweatshirts and
hoodies that's kind of scary all audio
books are five dollars you can get those
up until the last second because they're
all downloadable and that includes The
Total Money Makeover audiobook all for
five bucks these deals are great they're
amazing if you you don't take advantage
of this you got I don't know
you're missing out that's all I'm saying
I've got some question about your
Christmas spirit I mean everybody around
me this is what they're getting they
already know
this is your gift brand new products and
lots of things happening for our year
and sale a lot of these the question for
humans cards still on sale for 10 bucks
a lot of books are on sale for only 10
bucks be sure and check it all out the
Ramsey gold planner for 2023 is only
35.99 that's the lowest price it's ever
been and it is a fabulous use for your
goals for next year the year-end sale
ends at 11 59
today
yeah don't be dragging around here shop
these great deals right now
ramseysolutions.com store Scott's
weather Scott is in Phoenix hi Scott
welcome to the Ramsey Show
Merry Christmas everyone merry Christmas
how can we help
so
I don't do the baby steps I just been
listening to you and I'm debt free I
just have a mortgage and my question is
that I just came into some money which
is about thirty thousand dollars and I
want to invest it in retirement because
I'm hitting 53 and I really don't have
any retirement I have been paying into
my 401k every time I get a raise at work
I've been upping my 401. so for four
years I'm at right now at 400 a month
going into my 401. but I'd like to take
that 30 000 and put it into something
that would grow quickly
and you know that I would feel confident
about
I don't want to spend it I don't want to
you know just go out and blow it I'm
really starting to you know hit that age
I'm like I really do need to think about
retirement you married
yes I am married
um my wife has her retirement through
her work so she's been working on that
every you know she's been at the job for
about 15 years so she's got her
retirement established Okay jump online
at ramseysolutions.com and find a
smartvester pro in your area open a Roth
for this year in a Roth for next year
and do one for your wife as well so
that's 14 that's 28 000 bucks
okay and put it all in good growth stock
mutual funds across four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
International
now can I add to that you know the
following year of extra money the
following year after 24 after 23 you can
in 24. because I just funded 23 and 24
just then
okay because I want to be able to
because I have extra money left over uh
since I'm not in debt anymore I'd like
and I'm I want you to throw that towards
your mortgage
okay yeah I want to get I want to get 15
of your household income going into
retirement throw everything else towards
your mortgage I'm assuming you have an
emergency fund and you already said you
were debt free but the mortgage right
yes I got forty thousand dollars a day
in in my emergency fund
because I sold the house and I just
purchased this new house about six
months ago
so we were able to sell my old house for
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars I
put some of it into the new house and
then I just paid all our debt off cars
everything
and then I have as I said I got 40 000
left in the emergency fund for anything
good so that's work and then you know
and then I've been doing
500 extra months on the new house yeah
on top so here's the thing the baby
steps tell us to put 15 of your
household income into retirement we just
loaded up a couple of roths you've
already got your 401 and your watch 401
going so I'm going to guess and say
you're probably getting up to that 15
percent or beyond beyond that anything I
can find in my mortgage I want to get
this house paid off because the two key
things that we find that cause people to
be millionaires uh and it's not long
from now for you you're going to be
there pretty quick is a loaded up
retirement account or retirement
accounts and a paid for mortgage that's
right I want to make sure though that
you don't spend all of that money I mean
I want to make sure that you keep some
of it for three to six months of
expenses that's the one thing I don't
want him to it sounded like once he paid
off the debt he had that that 30 or 40K
left and that was kind of his nest egg
so I want to make sure that he keeps
some of that for us three to six months
of expenses as well yeah absolutely if I
was confused I thought you had 40 Grand
plus the 30 grand if you don't then
that's a different thing you need an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses that's baby step three four is
you're gonna put 15 of your income into
retirement between Roth IRAs 401K for
you 401K for your wife add it all up
50.15 times your annual income and you
need to be there and no more everything
else goes towards that mortgage let's
get that mortgage cleared uh because
that paid for house and uh you know half
million to a million dollars in your
mutual funds in your 401ks and Roth IRAs
is where you're going to uh that's where
you're going to reach that million
dollar net worth and Beyond of course
Jacob is in Elizabeth City North
Carolina hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thanks Dave I am calling because my wife
and I are in baby steps three and we
just found out that on her van needs a
new transmission and the cost of the
repairs is going to drain what we have
currently in our emergency fund so I say
go ahead and do it that's what the
emergency funds for let's get the van
fixed and always how much is it going to
cost to fix the van
so it's going to be 4 500 including
labor
and that's your whole three to six
months of emergencies fund no no we're
in baby step three okay so you haven't
completed it yet okay I see yeah we have
four thousand dollars so far so it will
be a three thousand dollar deposit and
then I think it gets out of 500 I mean
the other 500 to fix it what a year is
this man okay or something what year
2005
what's it worth
um I'm not sure I'm gonna look because
they haven't been looking to sell or
anything but it's a Honda Odyssey with
only like 160 000 miles on it
okay
um the first thing I'm always going to
do with transmissions and engines
is
um you real is this is like um the car
has cancer you don't go with one you get
multiple opinions you need a second
opinion and a third opinion not
necessarily does the transmission need
to be replaced but is there a more
economical way to get this transmission
replaced who gave you this bid the
dealer
no it's a local mechanic that's good so
we've been going to for a couple years
okay we trust them I trust him too
it doesn't sound outlandish but it is a
big enough expense I want you to get
some other opinions and uh I'm guessing
you have two cars right and this is one
of them
yeah so we have that her van and then I
have a 1998 Honda Accord with like 205
000 miles on it what's your household
what do you thinking
I have like a base of 60 and then I get
bonus on top of that so a base
sixty thousand oh sixty I thought you
said 16. I did too okay I feel better
already
um yeah me too okay so yeah yeah yeah
you fix the van that's what the
emergency fund's for
okay that's what I figured but I am
going to get a couple of bits not just
the one mechanic that I trust
uh and it may lead you right back to him
and I kind of think it's going to and
that's okay but you want you just want
to uh in the in the multitude of counsel
there is safety the Bible says where
there are options lots of options you
will choose a better choice than when
you have only one option or only two
options so I'm going to go talk to two
or three other people figure out is
there a more economical reasonable way
that that is reliable to get this
transmission replaced I doubt it
um I I don't think that's a bad price
off the top of my head but hey man you
might find somebody to do it for 3 500
and be worth looking I'm also wondering
what that van was worth
um Honda Odyssey they're 05 a way bit
pricey so
I don't know almost 200 000 miles yeah
um something to look at something to
look at for sure is it worth fixing
probably though it probably is this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
I'm Dave Ramsey your host Jade warshaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
we're glad you're with us
the phone number here for your life and
your money questions is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Sean is in Baltimore hey Sean welcome to
the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you guys great how can we
help
so I'll try and keep this brief um have
a unique situation my wife and I lost a
baby at 22 weeks back in April and had
to use some of my wife's unpaid FMLA
because she's a teacher she just gave
birth early at 27 weeks at the fifth of
this month and only has the remainder
the remaining eight weeks of FMLA to use
our daughter is in the NICU until the
end of January and my wife will have to
put in for a leave of absence to spend
time with our baby should we stop
investing until she begins getting paid
again even though we have our fully
funded emergency fund
I'm sorry to hear about the loss of that
first baby that's really tough but I'm
also celebrating with you on this new
birth which is definitely something to
celebrate
um how long of a leave of absence is she
planning to take
um
about seven weeks what do you make
um I met about three thousand dollars a
month yes you should stop investing
okay you gotta you're in the middle of a
storm
and so you gotta Batten up the hatches
as a temporary measure
that's right the same way the same way
we would suggest that if you were about
to have a baby that you would kind of
pause the baby steps and and stack up
extra cash this is kind of the same idea
but it's kind of on the back end yeah
you're on baby step four so it is a
little different but yeah you don't you
need the margin right now
um because you've had an unbelievably
emotional year
from miscarriage to acute NICU is is a I
mean you you've had and all having to do
with babies which keeps your stomach in
your throat all the time right yeah yeah
so you guys need the you need the the
mathematical margin to pay attention to
the child and to pay attention to where
you both are emotionally in the middle
of this trauma so that you process it
and you hold hands and you're looking at
each other's eyes and you hang on to
each other your Investment Portfolio
does not matter a flip for the next six
months that's right
okay thank you so much you humans are
what matter right now little ones are
big ones both
okay so just lean in be a good dad be a
good mom be a good husband be a good
wife
um you know we got one we got one job
and that is uh walking the rest of the
way through the these uh
you know these uh these storms that
you've been through they're two
different kinds of Storms and uh but but
NICU is a storm too in and of itself
right
absolutely every time I go to NICU with
a friend or a family and and walking
down there it takes my breath away does
it steal yours as a dad
yeah we're we've been going there for
two weeks now we've still got about
another month to keep going back still
hard to breathe when you walk in right
yeah yeah
I mean I gotta wait we had a team member
that had one in there 14 months we had
uh uh we've got
and by the way that kid's doing great
now
um so there is a good end of these
stories and the family's quote unquote
back to normal back to working back to
investing back to living life and so on
and uh another friend a friend as well
uh that that you know I guess we were
down there for uh seven or eight months
in and out of there and um it's just a
it's a it's a process and so it's a
period of your life that that is out of
control so you've got to control what
you can control and yeah you need the
margin you need the margin give yourself
permission to do nothing well right now
that's so good yeah and
um now do not get into
rational rationalization spending where
oh we've got to have this item and we're
gonna go forty thousand dollars in debt
no no no no no no no no don't go back
onto there but but but do protect the
household with the cash that you can for
right now
I love that simplification make
everything a simpler process and like
you said make sure that your focus on is
on really what matters which is your
family
well when you're in the middle of some
kind of storm crisis trauma whatever you
want to call it your vision immediately
you lose your peripheral vision and you
just get you get to focus on the one
thing to survive oh absolutely your
brain does that for you and you need to
do that with the math as well and that's
healthy that's good that's smart Trent
is in Phoenix hey Trent what's up
guys a long time listener first-time
caller so uh thank you for what you do
Dave I appreciate you well thank you
Merry Christmas how can we help yes yes
sir so I uh I'm debt free
um I have a kind of a side hustle for
years I've I've bought things and kind
of resold them but recently I started
getting into buying storage units uh and
then turning and selling them and my
concern though is this is kind of taken
off and I'm kind of on a trajectory to
you know kind of being a ballpark of 30
to 40 000 in profit and what I don't
want to do is type it in with my
personal finances and I guess the bigger
question is how do I avoid you know tax
issues should I do an LLC I just
honestly don't know where to go well
congratulations on your side hustle
that's pretty great I mean when when it
comes to a side hustle and I kind of
speak to this from my own perspective my
husband and I had a small business and
still do
um it really when you're starting with
the business whether you're a sole
proprietor or you know you do decide to
do an LLC even with an LLC and I mean
you can select this but most of the
profit and losses is passing through to
your your personal account anyway so
there's still does that make sense the
only thing in my mind that might make
you go towards an LLC would be the
liability side of it
and making sure that you're you're
covered and that if something were to
happen and somebody sued you they can't
go after your personal your personal uh
assets so in that in that way you might
look at an LLC or an S corp or something
like that yeah I would probably look at
an LLC in that case but I would not the
LLC does not give any tax benefit
there's no place to hide the taxes yeah
you gotta be right everybody's people
don't pay any taxes horse crap yes they
do too the more you make them more than
anything and more pay more than yours to
make but yeah so absolutely you pay
taxes and LLC a sub-ass a sole
proprietor all I have a hundred percent
pass through to your personal return
there is no avoiding squat uh now in any
business uh in any of those structures
uh any expense you have is a valid
expense reduces your income by that much
um but or if you have an item you
purchase that's depreciated and you'd
appreciate it over a one three five
fifteen 30-year schedule whatever it is
then you're going to get that savings as
well but uh but there is no thing of oh
well the way you do it is you do a
double backflip Family Trust LLC through
Nevada no that's a bunch of crap on some
infomercial it does not work he could
probably get with a local provider
though endorse local provider and find
an accountant to kind of help help him
open it up or walk through that exactly
but Jade is exactly right Trent when I
started doing llc's or sub-s's was when
it was was for risk management you need
business insurance for liability in
general
and if somebody gets hurt with one of
those containers or something like that
and then the second thing is if your
personal assets are big enough or if the
business has the appearance of being big
enough that it starts to have a Target
on it with these idiots that Sue
everybody left and right for nothing I
got a hangnail so I'm going to sue you
for two million dollars well now you
need the business separated off from
your personal stuff so it's it shrinks
the size of the Target that way and you
would open an LLC for that but you do
have an extra tax return When you do the
LLC you've got extra paperwork you have
to run every single thing regarding the
business in the name of the LLC that's
right otherwise it's invalid
it will pierce the corporate veil if you
don't and so you can't go fooling around
do some stuff in Trent's name some stuff
in the uh llc's name you know you've
done doing good then so
get a you know get like she said get
with one of the tax providers one of the
elps and they can help you with that
process
I think that's uh it's kind of like
there's so much mythology
around wealth and taxes is one of them
oh yeah you know everybody inherits
their money that's wealthy that's
absolute BS oh we know that we know that
statistically right and rich people
don't pay any taxes the more money you
make the more taxes you're paying pretty
simple if you're if you're turning money
into Cash every year that is taxable
income there's very very few things that
are otherwise one of the joys of earning
more
she says sarcastically this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today
so this article
oh man
Dave when I saw this article I I said
okay okay I gotta show this to Dave I
read it it says nearly half of young
adults in the U.S are living at home
with their parents and all that saved
money on rent is fueling a luxury boom
it says a record number of young adults
in the U.S are currently living at home
and all that saved money is sparking a
luxury boom that's unbelievable to me
because if you read down in the article
it says 48 of these young adults are
living with their parents this is 20
this is in 2022 so this is not like
from 2020 right we know that people kind
of hold up together because of the
pandemic in 2020 but it's still taking
place and it says that
it's because they have all this extra
money and instead of paying off I don't
know their debt this is a historical
High since the Great Depression yeah
these numbers have not been seen since
the Great Depression 48 so let me get
this straight you live in your mama's
basement but you got a Coach purse you
got a Coach purse and and these these
companies that are you know they make
Tiffany and Dior and Hennessey and all
these luxury Brands they saw a 20 Spike
above
and they're contr they're attributing it
to baby children from baby children and
at first Dave I'll be honest when I when
I first read this my my anger and my
frustration was at the Young Adult
but then I thought about it I thought
about it more and I said no no no no
this is a helicopter mama got out of
control helicopter Daddy got out of
control helicopter Mom this is also you
know it's a result in my mind
it's three things it's the parenting
right we've sent that message that
basically we're going to do everything
we're not parenting this is coddling cod
we've coddled the confidence right out
of these people we've coddled it right
that's tweetable think about it when
you've got parents who say I don't trust
that you can do this I don't trust that
you can make it out there on your own I
don't trust that you can use your
god-given intellect and skill to earn
money and pay rent why don't you come
back and live here and oh by the way
when you live here we'll cook your meals
we'll pay your rent you know if you need
a little gas for money we'll give you
that too then Dave you've got the
government saying hey you can't pay for
your student loans we'll do it for you
and then you've got this this mixture of
then now social culture telling you
everything you everything you say is
Right everything you think is right you
can do no wrong now tell me Dave how
does that create an adult who can go in
and function in society what this is
creating is uh for the particular young
people that are falling prey for it
is what's known as a train wreck it's a
train wreck you described a train wreck
because here's what's going to happen
you cannot avoid life you can
it's coming for your butt well that's
what's happened and mama can't protect
you
and Biden can't protect you nope and
your opinion doesn't matter until you've
got actual experience to base that
opinion on that's right but the world
has time to do that
I really don't care what your opinion is
the world
this this is different
the problem is when they do get in the
world and they will they will they're
going to run into reality which reality
says truthfully reality says you are not
an expert on something just because you
breathe air
your opinion is not valid that's right
unless it is based on some kind of facts
that were based on not feelings that's
right but you've been told that your
feelings are all valid and they are
valid feelings yeah but anybody that
leads their life by feelings is known as
a child adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good that's
right here's here's who we need to rant
at and you're exactly right Rachel Cruz
said this 10 years ago 15 years ago the
first time we don't have a student loan
crisis we have a parenting it's
parenting it's parenting and I say it
all the time you have to you can't
absorb everything for your kids now I've
got young kids Dave I've got
two-year-olds and you send them to the
salt mines every morning
pick up your toys it's very easy to want
to step in and not let them
fail not let them feel disappointment
not let them feel hurt you gotta let
them feel it here's the problem when
you're a parent that you think you are
doing your child a favor by making it
easy for them you're in actually making
it harder for them because you're stupid
well you're seeing a message that you
think that they're not going to have to
learn the lesson they have to learn
lessons so you're better off to learn
the lesson while at home and 15 years
old and feel the pain of calluses on
your hands feel the pain of actual
discipline and responsibility at a
reasonable level where I can protect you
from it being crushing pain that's right
as your dad but I'm gonna make sure that
you feel the abrasion so that when you
feel real abrasion later real adversity
later you've got the freaking character
to stand in the wind and the resilience
because if you don't allow that you're
again you're sending that message I
don't have confidence in you and there's
an undercurrent that the child feels
that okay I I can't do this so then when
they do get out in the world and all
those things happen they don't know how
to they don't know how to be resilient
they don't know how to handle it because
they have not had to build that level of
confidence and like you said character
and it's just I gave this example the
other day I was talking about my kid and
um you know he wants to help me set the
table at night and I look he's he's four
years old he's not gonna do it right
he's going to put the stuff on the edge
of the table probably Gonna Knock the
glass off it's going to break all these
things and I it's a great opportunity
for me to step in and go you know I'll
just do it I'll put it like this I know
how to do it but if I do that I'm
telling him I don't have confidence in
you to either do it right and I
certainly don't have confidence in you
to make a mistake and learn from it
there's no dignity there's no dignity
there when you are coddled you gotta let
him do it there is no dignity when you
have no autonomy because you have
absolutely no actual skills that's right
and by the way managing your social
media account is not a social it's not a
skill okay that you don't qualify for
that one okay that one doesn't count you
don't get making comments on other
people's actual achievements is not a
skill yeah that's not an achievement you
didn't achieve anything when you did
that yeah and so when you live in your
mother's basement and you write a blog
on Personal Finance the rest of the
world laughs at you yeah and your mommy
thinks you're cute so a message to these
young adults living at home you've been
enabled we're telling you you've been
enabled you have been coddled you have
been put in a situation that is not for
your best interest now it is time for
you to do something to change that
it's time for you to get up it's time
for you to get out the problem is not I
can't afford rent that is a symptom the
problem is you've got debt you're not
earning enough money and you're not
doing enough to go out and change it Mom
and Dad can't do this for you wow and
don't blame it on the fact that folks
are getting married later in life
because that's a whole other thing no
it's not it's look work more go to the
bar less
was that was that okay that that's it
because you you took it you took your
beer pong skills from college and you
brought them home to your 23 year old
self and you converted them to happy
hour skills yeah and so we live from
Thank God It's Friday to oh God it's
Monday and this is the recipe for
freaking failure so if you're a young
person listening to us we are not
picking on you we are begging you to get
away from your parents they're stupid
they did they did you wrong and parents
if you're listening in the New Year it's
time for you to serve a notice that's
the gift the gift that they need to open
up is a a pink slip yep you got toast
you got till March you got till June
yeah no more than June June's Max but uh
I mean give them give them an exit ramp
give them an on-ramp give them an off
ramp whatever you want to call it but
let's lay out a game plan coach them
help them and show them what to do and
let me just tell you an eagle that does
not leave the nest is eventually known
as a turkey
they are useless you do not want to be
38 and living in your mother's basement
by the way young men no woman wants to
date you because you're what's known as
a wuss
you are not eligible you are not
eligible you look like a parasite you do
not look like a person who can carry
half of a relationship oh my goodness my
daughter I wish my daughter would bring
home a dude that's living in his parents
basement oh big Sam be lighting that got
up
all right
hey seriously folks love your children
well enough to cause them to grow up
that's right and out
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of the choice we help people
build wealth the work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we take your questions about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Merry Christmas to you
America we're so glad you're here well
folks I'll give you a little statistics
as we wrap up this year uh this will be
our last live broadcast of the year as
we head into Christmas season here uh
the last few days of before Christmas
and after Christmas and so forth
um I'm trying to look up here we took uh
did 233 live shows this year we talked
to
147 millionaires that means about every
about every uh one and a half shows we
talked to a millionaire
um we did 358 debt-free screams
that accounted for 61 million dollars a
little over 61 million dollars in debt
paid off just screamed about on the air
and um
and that's in on about 2 900 calls that
we took this year about 3 000 calls we
took on the air so we do three hours of
this show live every day from one to
four central time it is broadcast on 680
talk radio stations we are the second
largest Talk Radio Show in America Sean
Hannity is number one and we are number
two and there's not even a close third
no one's even in that in in the same
ballpark that he's in or we're in in
terms of listenership or in terms of
stations cleared actually Sean has a has
fewer stations than we have but more
listeners because he's got better time
slots uh he's owned by I heart and so
they put him on premium time slots in
all of their stations so but he does a
great job too he's a friend and does
we're proud for him everything is good
and uh he just does a really good job so
uh that's the talk radio side and uh
then there's the podcast side which is
now had a billion downloads
there are five shows in the world
that have had a billion downloads Joe
Rogan Dave Ramsey the two largest
um and so not even close uh you know and
I mean there's a there's almost a
billion podcasts probably I don't know
there's millions of them it feels like
but uh everybody with a computer in a
bedroom is doing a podcast which is fine
there's some good ones out there they're
fun to listen to I listen to a bunch of
different things George and Rachel
launched the smart money smart or
something
smart money Happy Hour podcast and it's
really good listen to it this morning on
my walk as a matter of fact the one that
dropped today and so check those out
but that's just a few of the numbers of
the things that are going on around here
YouTube uh you know we've got our little
button over here over a million
subscribers we've had that for a long
time uh we're one of the top producers
and uh all of minutes viewed in all of
YouTube and uh just uh amazing amazing
results and all of that is you folks
thank you yep
um I mean we're here to help you and um
you've uh joined our humor you've joined
our caustic sarcasm uh you've joined our
our approach to this whole process from
our faith you've uh you've in you've
joined in with us on telling everyone
about the shows and the various formats
there's about 24 25 million of you
between YouTube podcast and talk radio
in a given week and so thank you thank
you it's 61 million dollars worth of
debt free screens last year that's so
fun I I'm looking at these stats you
know all the all the debt that's been
paid off all the millionaires that's
called this year 358 debt free screams
and it reminded me of something I saw
this morning someone posted they had
they had some debt and they posted and
they said you know I bought this car it
was for 35 000 and my plan was to pay
off ten thousand between August and
December well that didn't happen I just
haven't felt motivated enough to
aggressively pay it off and she said I
think I had the most success when I saw
other people's debt progress but there
doesn't seem to be much of that going on
these days she's in the wrong Community
she needs to get over here because we're
paying off debt we're becoming
millionaires we're changing our lives
and we are following a plan that we've
seen work with millions and millions of
people she's got the wrong folks around
her she needs to come and get in this
Ramsey Camp amen for 30 years 30 years I
need to learn to do it the Ramsey Way
and that's not Dave Ramsey said that's
not what anything can do with it this is
gods and Grandma's ways of handling
money it used to be called common sense
and now it's so rare it's like having a
superpower well so so we became one of
the most downloaded watched viewed
listened toed repeated shows in the
entire freaking world and all we do is
tell you to live on less than you make
simple as that
simple principle is hard to do hey
Ramsey you don't say anything new I said
yeah but I say it better and more often
than you do so it worked there you go
that's all I did there is nothing the
the irony is I mean my preacher told me
that day he said you say the same thing
over and over again I said so do you
you just keep coming back to one story
all the time
that is so good well you know the thing
about it is you got to actually put it
into action you got to do it yeah you
hear you'll hear it and you say oh I get
it but are you actually doing it are you
are you not actually putting it that's
the longest journey in the world from
the brain to the heart yo yeah that's a
hundred miles right there you know it's
a leak from the brain down into the
heart and cause you to actually go
freaking do it it's all about your
little do it
I mean that that just requires something
right there that's it you know it's it's
directing your will into the right place
it's a we we know that we you know
people talk about a lot about willpower
but we know that we have free will and
your will is simply your desire to put
fixated effort into something
and when it comes to this money stuff we
wait we sit around and wait for
motivation or we wait for somebody to
say it I don't know a billionth more
time right you've said this stuff a
million times Dave but there comes a
point where you have to assert your will
into it
you have to assert your will you have to
say I'm going to put all of my fixated
and focused effort onto this path
and when you do that you change your
husband can't do it for you no your wife
can't do it for you and we sure can't do
it I can't do it for you yep and I can't
do it for you all we can do is give you
the information that's right and the
proof the social proof that's right
358 people doing debt free screams in
the calendar year 2022 live on the air
on this show paying off 61 million plus
yup dollars of debt uh uh you can't do
it why those people fixated their will
on it Dave they said I'm gonna get this
thing done I'm gonna change my life I
can change my life and I'm not gonna sit
around and wait for anybody else I've
heard it enough times I've heard live on
less than you make I've heard you know
get out of debt debt is dumb cash is
King I've heard you got to do a budget
and these people finally said enough
enough listening time to start doing hey
help us by subscribing by sharing the
show and by leaving a five-star review
don't need anyone Stars your mama said
if you can't say something nice don't
say nothing at all this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay barshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today
10 million folks have gone through
Financial Peace University and chances
are if you did it's because someone in
your life lit a fire under you your mom
or dad gave it to you as a gift your
pastor offered it at your church a
friend wouldn't shut up about it so you
finally took the class and now
everything's changed well maybe it's
time for you to do that for someone else
maybe you're that Mom or Dad or that
Pastor or that friend you can give
someone you care about Financial Peace
University share the same hope and
freedom you've discovered with money
that's a cool thing to get for Christmas
hope and freedom
to buy FPU as a gift go to
ramseysolutions.com give FPU that's
ramsaysolutions.com give FPU Justin's
with us in Portland Oregon hi Justin
Merry Christmas
hey you guys too thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey um so we and my wife and I finished
maybe step two about eight months ago
and uh which included roughly forty
eight thousand dollars in student loan
debt congrats and
um so we didn't have any debt and
um
my wife found out a couple months ago
that she qualified for twenty thousand
dollars and the student loan forgiveness
program
and which how we didn't have any debt
and she qualified for that I have no
idea why that is or how that is
um so she applied and we were approved a
couple weeks ago we got a check from the
United States Treasury for forty
thousand dollars oh crap and I'm like
okay well that's a little odd first of
all we only qualify for twenty thousand
so why do we have a check for 40 well
there are let's wait a minute stop there
has been no student loan forgiveness
that's right
well so so what they did is I put your
loan back on the books yep
that's exactly what they did
so they I looked into it and
um
they they reopened her student loan and
charted it the exact amount that's on
this check that we received yep they
gave you they gave you a refund because
you're because your debt was already
paid and you qualified for this and
maybe they I don't know I don't know why
they doubled it maybe they assumed you
did the original balance uh the original
ah so they put it all back oh these guys
are Scoundrels man the these oh so yeah
I mean they went from having no debt to
now having a debt of forty thousand two
hundred people just send the checks back
and tell them to close the account and
don't apply for student loan forgiveness
again
okay now that was my question I didn't
want to cash it because no one won't be
taxed on it this whole thing is oh it's
not taxable it's not taxable there's no
taxes on it but what what you may end up
doing is you may end up having to pay
some interest because you now have a
fifty thousand dollar loan on the books
again
so you need to get the table and my
guess is you're going to have to cash it
and then make a payment and pay the loan
off again that's right
yeah and and the student loan uh
servicer they do not know what's going
on we've called three or four times and
we've gone three or four different
answers they're showing no balance
no they're showing the balance that the
check is for still okay yeah um but they
do know what's going on too they're
acting like they don't know what's going
on they know what's going on they know
they now have a loan that they are
charging interest on again they are
happy campers send that money back go go
today yeah close that account today and
I'm afraid that your wife's screwing
around with this might have cost you
have four or five hundred dollars
interest we'll we'll see when the Smoke
Clears on this hopefully not and that
goes for anybody Dave do if your loan is
a zero balance do not go back into debt
to to possibly get this money yeah it's
it's too risky there there's not enough
information going on with that and and
we can listen to a call like this and
see they he didn't even request the 48
000 they just opened up the whole amount
of the loan back yeah it's very it's
very Sinister it's very nefarious what
these folks are doing and I don't like
it and if I'm if I'm y'all I'm not
getting involved in it you're debt free
be debt free walk away
walk away walk away so get you know
you're gonna have to treat this like you
have a 48 000 loan balance because you
do and you have 48 000 check in your
hand cause you do so my guess is you're
going to make a deposit of that you're
going to write a check and close the
loan out again and whatever period of
time this gyration has been going on
you're probably going to have some
interest due and um you might even have
a late charge because you haven't been
paying your payments properly yeah guys
don't let the lure of free money
lead somebody who's otherwise smart into
doing something stupid do not do not
fall for that wow
let's kind of back up about two steps
here's what exactly happened technically
okay there is no
student loan forgiveness program as of
this date
period
there is not a loan forget the the Biden
uh student loan forgiveness program is
is under several lawsuits going before
The Supreme Court on February the 28th
the hearings begin they may go on for
months or years but they begin
to decide if Biden's student loan
forgiveness program is going to go
forward today it does not exist
okay so you do not need to apply for
something today don't do that does not
exist this is just what his wife did was
she said my grandmother what big eyes
you have that's right thank you little
Hood red and Hyde oh my God this is a
carrot that started as a bright orange
shiny carrot dangling in front of our
eyes but trust me by the time this goes
through the Supreme Court and months and
months and maybe years of litigation
it's going to be an old rotten carrot
that's driven a lot of us into making
bad decisions well what what his wife
did
and bless your heart she was trying to
do something smart she was trying to get
money back
from a loan she'd already paid off that
she may qualify for if this does go
through when it does go through but they
don't have a mechanism
the government nor the student loan
provider does not have a mechanism to do
student loan forgiveness because it does
not exist today
yeah okay the court has not cleared it
there is not a program there it doesn't
exist and so what they did was they said
oh you really didn't mean to pay off
your student loans you'd like to keep
them there in case forgiveness comes
through and so we're going to give you
your money back that you paid off the
loan and put the loan back on the books
so when and if forgiveness comes along
we'll be able to give you the
Forgiveness against of twenty thousand
against the forty eight thousand right
that's what that's what they did and if
people aren't careful that money is
going to be sitting there and whenever
interest starts back
people who aren't watchful that's a good
point there won't be any interest on it
there won't be but what is it March I
told him there might be interest charged
on this well if he lets it sit if you
let that money sit until forgiveness
takes place but I I did tell him there
might be interested now and I was wrong
not yet not yet yeah that was a Miss but
I still want him to take that check and
it could be a late charge it could be a
late charge for not paying payments oh
yeah well no payments right now but the
point is the point is if you're not
careful if you take your eye off the
ball in this situation that money will
be sitting in your account you will have
forgotten about it right because it's
just sitting there and you've got this
check that you're kind of holding on as
well waiting and and you're trusting
yourself to not spend that forty eight
thousand dollars during Christmas time
during inflation during the start of a
new year that is a very precarious
situation to put yourself in we really
it's been a hard year we really need a
vacation oh man and and my cousin's
wedding is coming up in the Caribbean
and we gotta get a car you know that car
we have to get a car you know we do and
and and you know we need it we need a
new van for those twins there's no
question yeah that's the kind of crap
that's going to happen all over America
it's already happening yep because they
do not have a mechanism to process your
student loan forgiveness check because
there is not a policy in place to do it
today that is approved it's in the
courts and those servicers can't wait to
issue your fake refund back in debt they
just got you they made you alone yep
they couldn't wait to do it
and they call it Dave a refund
that's what I hate they're calling it
they're they're they're they're they're
putting positive vocabulary around it so
it feels like we're getting some sort of
prize but there's no prize to be gotten
yet
well that's a prize but it's not one of
the trophies you want
it's your I got back into debt cries
oh Justin I'm sorry what a mess for you
honey yeah oh we're not making fun of
You Justin you're your wife we're trying
to tell these folks out here trying to
do it everything everything under the
heading student loan if you just say
that first everything second says sucks
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Christina's in Chicago hi
Christine how are you
I'm will how are you thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um I'm currently a resident physician
and I'll be graduating in six months I
recently signed my contract and received
a signing bonus of about 43 000 after
taxes I currently have about seventy
thousand dollars in total credit card
debt and personal loan debt and I'm
looking for the best way to use my
signing bonus current income and future
income to kind of get out of debt that's
great what's your income going to be
once you start working
375 000. oh girl I love to hear it
that's great well you know um what is it
now as a resident
um 70. when do you start
September good for you congratulations
you've worked a long time and you've
worked really hard to get here
congratulations
thank you I appreciate that
you know if I'm you I'm going to work
through this I'm gonna I'm gonna work
the the baby steps through this because
I want you to be able to enjoy that
income and I want you to you know be
able to live that life that you're
you've worked for as quickly as possible
have you started working the baby steps
thus far
I have not okay so let's walk through
that real quick so the way we teach this
this is going to be the best uh most
effective way to manage your money and
ultimately get to the fact to where
you're hopefully a millionaire and
you're living like no one else and being
generous so this is the path to get
there
the first thing we want to do is we want
to make sure you get a thousand dollars
saved so I know that you have that 43k
of bonuses do you have any other money
laying around
no that's it that's it okay so we're
going to take 1K we're going to set it
aside that is your starter emergency
fund it's not meant to be the beyond all
this is just temporary right so that's
thing one baby step two is you're paying
off all of your debt except your
mortgage so in this case we've already
put a thousand dollars aside for the
emergency fund you've got 42k left am I
right correct so if I'm you I'm gonna go
ahead and put that money towards my debt
snowball now as it stands right now with
your your current salary you're paying
your bills everything's happening and
everything's rolling right you should
you should have you know even more money
to put towards your debt snowball so
what I want you to do as part of baby
step two is I want you to get on a
budget
have you have you been using a budget
thus far as that kind of A New Concept
for you
no I have a budget it it fails at times
or I guess I fail the budget okay okay
yeah I'm glad you said that next part
because the budget I mean you make it
right it's your plan that you're putting
putting together and that plan needs to
be on purpose and on par with what your
life demands so if the budget is failing
it's because we're not being detailed
we're not being realistic we're not
being flexible within our budget so I
want you to make sure that you are
planning for every single dollar and at
the end of the day it's you who's got to
decide I'm going to stick to this budget
and I'm going to do what I've said I'm
gonna do here's a really cool thing you
should be 100 debt free before Halloween
I know that's right
and um because you're
um
you said you start in September right
yeah okay but between now and then you
make 70 000 a year and we're gonna put
42 000 towards 70 leaving 30.
um so you've your debts when you list
them smallest to largest what is your
largest debt
okay so you can pay everything but that
or no no what's the next largest one
the next largest one is a six thousand
dollar credit card so you've got a bunch
of ankles
I do okay so you've got a list of things
that's probably 20 long and you're going
to get rid of the majority of that list
with the signing bonus in one Fell Swoop
boom
that's gonna feel really good and the
good news about those little ankle
biters is you're going to be able to
feel winds very regularly right because
you're going to knock out those first
several with this chunk of money and
then you know every couple weeks you I
want to see you paying something off
every couple of months you know you're
paying off these little eight and one
thousand dollar things and two thousand
dollar things you're gonna be feeling
those wins uh how long has it been since
you've used a credit card
for a purchase
um this week this last Saturday yeah I
thought so there you go Dave there's
where your budget's going
because you've got you've got a pocket
full of credit cards you're used to
using these things so here's your
painful experience
when you get off the phone
uh are you you're not studying to be a
surgeon by chance are you
I am
here's your time to practice I want you
to have plastic surgery when you get off
the phone I want you to chop up every
one of those credit cards into little
bitty pieces and then every time you
close every time you pay off one I want
you to close the account and never
reopen it make sure your bank you get on
the phone with your bank today and get a
debit to card if you don't have one on
your checking account and anytime you
get ready to purchase something from
this point forward use a debit card you
got Amazon Prime
I sure do jump on there and change out
for your debit card
take the credit card off of it
okay are you gonna do it Christine I am
okay that's gonna help you do the budget
it is because what's happening is it's
too easy for you to fall off the wagon
yeah because you got fake money laying
around
you got extra make it hard no extra fake
money yeah make it hard to spend money
you don't mean to spend if you're going
to spend money on purpose that's fine
I've got I mean we've got Amazon Prime
at the Ramsay house and it's just got a
debit card attached to it but I know
when I click that button or Sharon knows
when she clicks that button that real
money just left a real account
it's not fake money and that credit card
money is fake money it'll catch up on
you it's not emotional so okay so you're
going to have an emotional experience
that's positive in a whole bunch of ways
you're going to feel this weird
transformational thing when you chop up
all your credit cards get the debit card
on Amazon Prime get the debit card on
anything where you used to have a credit
card get out of the credit card business
and you're going to take this check and
clear through more than half of your
list yeah all these little 100 200 500
things are just going to go out to like
a hot knife through butter you're gonna
knock off a whole bunch of them and then
you're still going to be staring at a
pretty decent list but every time you
get a check in now you're more under
control you're spending and you're going
to be able to attack it this is so cool
Christine I'm so proud of you it's great
I gotta highlight the fact this is going
to feel counter cultural
counter-cultural to what you think
security is because you thought
counter-intuitive thank you
counterintuitive you thought security
was having credit cards at something to
fall back on you thought security was
maybe I can have this signing bonus I'll
just hold on to it it's a nice little
cushion even if I have debt and we're
telling you to do things that are
opposite of what security comes from you
taking control that's right
you telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went
that's right you're going to get a sense
of power like you've had you remember
when you the power Christine when you
started working through the syllabus to
get to be an MD yeah yeah you know and
you started I knocked that class out I
knocked that class out I knocked that
I'm that much closer I'm that much
closer I'm that much closer I'm running
a half marathon I'm at Mile nine that's
right I've got I've you know I've got
four and a half to go here I go and 4.3
to go right so there we go I mean that
kind of stuff so you you're you're
clicking off the miles you're clicking
off the traction and you've never done
that with money
and so you're going to get this positive
feeling but it is also it's a
transformational thing so it's going to
be uncomfortable for the first 90 days
that you live in this she's proving the
concept exactly that's so I just wanted
her to be emotionally prepared for that
but she's doing all right she's doing it
right she's doing it right it's so good
because you know the thing is the weird
thing folks is y'all think that these
doctors that make a lot of money are
rich most of them are broke um
I mean we MDS are as bad as pro athletes
they're just horrible with money I mean
they're just Mo I mean there's some pro
athletes that do a good job with money
and there's some MD's that do a good job
with money yeah but stereotypically you
know we always think of the doctor and
the lawyer or the rich people in town
especially old people like me that's
right used to be in the 50s you know the
people sitting on the Chamber of
Commerce were the rich ones right and
that's just the doctor the lawyer the um
the college professor
um and these are these are the wealthy
people in the in the town the little
town and uh the weird thing is these
doctors a lot of them do very well on
their income side that's right but
they've piled themselves up with that
Christine's not that bad she's only got
seventy thousand but your income is not
your net worth
exactly your income you can make
hundreds of you know several hundred
thousand dollars a year you make
millions of dollars and be broke we hear
it all the time we well we we've done
the studies on Millionaires and we see
its teachers engineers and these people
they're not making hundreds of thousands
of years they're not making 300 400 000
a year now that's interesting 33 percent
of the millionaires in the study never
made over 100k one third one out of
three something to think about this is
the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Paul is with us in
Cincinnati Ohio Merry Christmas Paul
Merry Christmas Dave and Jade how are
you great how can we help
all right so I'll jump right into the
question
um right now I have a 25
000 whole life policy and I'm in baby
step two I'm wondering if I should
cancel the policy and get the cash value
out of it to apply to my debt snowball
but the kicker is that I am not
insurable for term life insurance well
you're not insurable for any life
insurance if you're not insurable for
term what's wrong with you
so in the past couple years I've lost
about 200 pounds but I'm still a little
bit above the weight limit for his life
insurance the 25 000 policy that I have
right now I was able to get when I
started my last job and there was no
medical exam required yeah you got that
you're paying through the nose for that
for sure so what do you weigh now
right now I'm about 350.
okay have you talked to Xander
I tried to talk to him and they said the
only thing they could do was off uh
policy I couldn't afford
I mean way up there and it wasn't for
anything that would cover what I needed
okay so yeah you're not insurable then
that's what it must do they they were
able to make a market but you're but
you're weight loss and you're still not
down to the common Extreme Weight Loss
is is a negative Believe It or Not
shouldn't be but it is a negative and
still still being at 350 is a negative
so uh that that's where you're getting
you're not but you can't get whole life
life insurance either
um no I can't add anything to what I got
right now what I have is enough to cover
burial right pay off the one last debt
before my federal student loans in our
debt snowball yeah what do you mean
uh right now I make about 50 000 a year
our family like our household incomes
are on 115. okay all right
well you're doing well with your income
um Congratulations by the way on the
weight loss how'd you do that
thank you combination of uh surgery as
well as lots of exercising diet over the
past few years since the surgery okay
yeah eat less exercise more go figure
who knew that's exactly it yeah okay so
yeah I'm
I'm proud of you that's pretty amazing I
mean you've changed your whole life
already uh I'm gonna tell you to just
continue the journey and get back down
to a more normal height weight ratio and
it may take a year or even two after
that before you're going to qualify
yep they told me I could get it if I had
sustained weight loss below their weight
limit but I'm still not quite there but
I'm still working but sustained would be
like a year to two is what I'm saying
yeah that's about right exactly that's
what I figured that's that's a fair
thing and so it gives you yet another
reason for the Target
um and uh not to mention the fact that
you feel better not to mention the fact
you feel better about yourself
emotionally way to go man I'm so proud
of you that's a very difficult Journey
very good the good news
yeah for real
um yeah a small one literally yeah for
real man way to go well Merry Christmas
Paul I wish I had a better answer for
you I'd keep that whole life policy in
place until you get past this uh final
stage of regaining your health
congratulations very well done
hey guys uh
that's we talk about life insurance
around here all the time and we throw it
around you know always get 15 to 20 year
level term 10 to 12 times your income
here's the thing
there are two things you can do
and Paul's an extreme example but there
are two things you can do that
dramatically affect the pricing
of your life insurance that are under
your control if you smoke
it's double that's right just like that
okay period and you know they pretty
well in our culture today now smoking's
not cool it's not like the 1950s right
yeah so um and there's lots of ways to
get out there and quit yeah there's I
mean it's a decision it is uh it is a
tough thing to kick the habit oh yeah
I've never smoked but um but but I
understand it's very hard to get away
from the nicotine so uh but uh it's
worth it because if nothing else you
save half yeah on your life insurance
that's pretty incredible not to mention
all the health benefits not to mention
here when you kiss your spouse you don't
taste like an ashtray so there's all
that's an expensive habit in many ways
yeah so uh your clothes stink everything
so the the second thing is uh
obesity yep being overweight yeah and uh
these are things we control
um as I've told you all here on the air
many times during covet I was a lot of
high stress working here I gained a
whole bunch of weight and uh I got just
straight up fat eating to every donut in
the dadgum 50 50 mile radius that was a
decision yeah and then to not do that is
a decision and so
um I still qualify at 62 years old for
premium pricing on life insurance
because my heart rate my weight ratio
all the you know the lifestyle choices
all of those things if I want life
insurance I don't want it I don't need
it today but um these are things you can
set yourself up for now there's things
you can't control but uh you know other
health issues you have a heart problem
you have a cancer problem those are
things you can't control on your life
insurance but more people overpay for
life insurance on Obesity or smoking
than any other all other factors put
together right oh yeah I believe it the
good news is if you you know like that
last call you know he he's walked the
journey he's he's proven that he has the
discipline and he's got the systems in
place to lose that weight and you know I
think a lot of those same mechanisms
apply for money I think and my guess is
probably when you put that when you put
on I'm not going to say how many pounds
it was a lot with those donuts you
already had the mechanisms in your brain
yeah that you could just pull from and
go hey I know how to be disciplined well
just like I told him it's not you eat
less than you exercise more so no more
Donuts fat boy I mean it's a hard art
it's a pretty straight up thing
simple can be hard though Dave yeah you
know simple can it's a simple method but
it takes effort and can be difficult to
put that so you guys first of the year
coming up here and you know what the
three largest New Year's resolutions are
get out of debt lose weight quit smoking
yeah got to be and then actually run
together is my point they do they it's
and Jade's point is is that they they
all have to do with this thing called
self
control self-control it's a fruit of the
spirit it is self-control
it's a beautiful thing it's a it's a
reservoir that you can you can pull from
when you've had self-control in one area
you know you can do it and when you come
to another area of life where you say
you know what I need to I need to enact
that same mechanism and I need to have
some self-control here you know that
you've done it before it's a well that
you can draw from man that guy's
impressive I'm so proud of it yes Sarah
and Waco go quick what's your question
I just have a couple questions for one
for starting your Financial Peace
University and January 18th with our
church good and I was just wondering
um I have stuff in collections but I
don't know how much I know one is about
nine thousand dollars for a credit card
for Wells Fargo but there's a couple
other things and in the past my sister
um used mine and my mom's social
security number and everything well
that's called identity theft that means
your sister's a criminal
yeah but it didn't do anything about it
I know but you don't owe the money
uh and get a you know file a victim's
report on that those debts now the ones
that are in collections that you haven't
paid I would set those aside until you
get the debts paid off that you are
current on if you're making payments
like on your car let's get that paid off
you got a credit card you're making
payments on let's get that paid off in
Financial Peace University before you go
clean up the old bad debt so you're
going to kind of run two debt snowballs
first your active real ones and then
secondly your old ones I like it sounds
like it sounds like a plan to succeed
yeah and you're gonna have to file uh
fill out a police report on the on the
fact that your identity was stolen the
sad thing is you know the criminal yeah
your family did you wrong I'm sorry that
happened
it's amazing the amount of uh identity
theft that occurs uh because someone
feels like they have the right because
they happen to be blood yeah yep we see
it all the time yeah but that makes you
the lowest kind of scum if that's you
doing that by the way
so um and it's also why we make sure you
put Xander Insurance's Identity Theft
Protection in place
that puts a sour of the Ramsay show in
the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual
amazing relationships Jade warshaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host tutay
Merry Christmas America open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're so glad you're with us
Julie's in Akron Ohio hi Julie welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi
um Merry Christmas to you all I'm so
excited to be on the show we're honored
to have you how can we help thank you
okay so I'm in the middle of my husband
and I uh baby steps four five and six uh
we just paid off all of our that college
uh his college loans and things like
that and what we have now is
um a 350 or 50 000 left on our home and
then we also have two kids uh going to
college and what one is going in the
next year and a half and the other one
is going in three years so I with the
money that we have at the end of the
month should I just just put everything
into the college funds right now they
each have fifty thousand dollars yes so
I have a total of a hundred yes yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna load up College it's
it's bearing down on you it's right in
front of you so I'm just going to load
that up it doesn't necessarily have to
be in a 529 at this stage you're not
going to gain much interest or much
growth that's tax free because you're
right there
um okay and uh yeah I want to I want to
you know start really uh researching the
cost of the schools that we're talking
about and uh what it's going to take to
get them through that and then lean into
that and try to get that try to get that
number going
um okay how much of you already got
saved for college
so I have 50 000 each for each so a
hundred thousand for for both right now
I also have okay and then I have a
hundred fifty thousand in our emergency
fund and I know that is high but yeah um
why do you have it like that why why did
you do that I don't know I can change
that it's just it's just been sitting
there and um I'm I don't know if I
should take you know put it yes let's
change that you need to take a hundred
thousand and put it in mutual funds get
it earning some money it's just sitting
there okay so now so now you've got now
you've got uh a hundred thousand per kid
for college now you really need to start
sitting down and going where are they
going to go to school
okay which I I I'm pretty sure my son is
going local so I think 50
to cover him but as far as my daughter
I'm not I'm not sure she's the the one
that's three years away but but you
never know
well
um
it doesn't happen to you you happened to
it so what we're doing now is we're
going to start telling her where she's
going to school yeah getting real
numbers and not not like waiting for her
to discover it
um okay so we're gonna start talking
about this is the money that we have and
this is where these are the types of
things places you can go with the money
we're going to have now if your son goes
local uh are you saying Community
College or there's a four-year School in
the area and he would live at home or
what
yes there's a four-year University close
there's there's a couple and he he wants
to live at home I think um we want him
to go away to get the college experience
but I think he's more comfortable this
is what he's telling us now that's fine
um so you know go to that college and
let's talk about what the actual tuition
is it's probably eight or ten thousand
dollars and so four years of that you
probably do have that covered
and so we may be once we kind of now
let's start doing the same thing with
daughter even though she's a little bit
away okay what are you thinking about
studying where where can you study that
would you go to uh you know Ohio State
University where you're going to go
um you're going to go over to Columbus
you know what are you going to do let's
start looking at what that actually
costs you may have enough to do both of
them if he's going to stay home
that's okay well she probably does I
mean she's got 50k per kid already
well I was going to say and then she's
got the 100 000.
okay you're right 50
000 is the emergency fund
okay if if 50 covers your son now your
daughter has a hundred and fifty
well she did and you're done and you
need to start paying down your house
Julie did you say that you already had
50 for both kids plus the 100 that we're
pulling from here yeah
yes okay so and if 50 covers her son
then she's got 150 for the daughter you
probably got your daughter covered oh
yeah you're doing you're doing good
that's why I want you to dial it in
because I think you can stop maybe step
five now that we've reallocated this if
you do a little bit of research and
become comfortable with the facts and
your daughter doesn't think she's going
to uh Harvard because she's not no no so
Dave would you I have a question would
you set would you set the budget and say
the budget is eighty thousand dollars
would you look for schools
I mean I'm fine with this in-state
tuition in State University so she's in
Akron Ohio Ohio State University is an
example which by the way is not a cheap
in-state school but um a little bit
pricey but uh but it's good school and
so academically and you can go and
they're playing football apparently too
so um you know so anyway you can do all
that and you can uh you know look at
college experience college experience is
way down on my list of things to do but
um yeah but I don't I don't I'm I you
know you're probably looking at uh I
have to look it up but I'm gonna guess
and say 12 to 15 000 for Ohio State plus
storm plus books yep plus food and so
you're probably over a hundred
uh pretty easily yeah uh for for a four
year by the time she gets there if she's
going to do a traditional four-year plan
and uh that you know so we got to start
mapping that out but once the thing
about goals is if you'll get detailed on
your goals yeah detailed on your sons
and it's not I think this is what he's
going to do we're going to talk you
through okay now this is the money I'm
setting aside based on this discussion
so this is what you're gonna do yeah and
then the same thing with the daughter
you know we're gonna you within this
we're going to use Ohio State as a
template and if you don't want to go
there you're going to go to somewhere
that is priced at that or less because
we're going to lock that down and then
every other dollar above that I'm gonna
start dumping on that mortgage and
getting rid of it I know that's right I
know and so you're going to be in a good
shape there yeah so the good news is you
uh cheated on the emergency fund but it
allows you to probably finish up baby
step five with a little bit of research
and detail detail detail detail here's
the weird thing
the
ambivalent the unknown
creates 10x the stress
that the known does even if the known is
tough if I know
I've got an uphill climb to get there
but I know the details of that climb it
is less stressful than oh it might be
hard it might be it's just to climb I
don't know what it is you know so you
when you detail out this tuition yeah
books
dorm yeah this is the plan yeah even if
it's more money than you got at least
you know the size of the Dragon right
and your mind can rest a little bit the
in in the unknown that's where the fear
is and that's when you start spinning
your wheels constantly yeah just burns
many many more calories mental calories
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you are with us our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they're the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code Ramsay to get the
best possible deal
today's question comes from Brook in
Texas we are newly married and just
completed baby step one I just graduated
from college and do not have a job but
start my new job next month making 16 an
hour full time my husband is currently
in the military and is getting released
but we don't know when he is getting
honorably discharged my question to you
is this should we start working on baby
step two or should we work on saving our
three to six month emergency fund all
right Brooke here's what I'm thinking
so we know that we have a possible I'm
not going to call it a job loss but a
job shift coming up and what I don't
want you guys to do is wait
until you you know I don't want you to
wait until he's discharged and then have
him looking for a job I want you guys to
start putting out feelers now so we can
start to kind of close that Gap and the
way I would approach this is I would
start stacking up money as though you
were going to put it onto your debt
snowball but I would kind of set it
aside and and once this once this this
Smoke Clears of these job transitions
then I want you putting that money onto
baby step two I don't want you to keep
it there I don't want you to do the baby
steps out of order it's not going to be
your three to six months emergency fund
it's just going to be money stacked up
in case you do have that job loss and
then I want you to put it to baby step
two on the Smoke Clears what do you
think Dave that's fine
um
traditionally Brooke we see too often
folks transitioning out of the military
wait until they're out of the military
to start their job look that's a mistake
you need to go ahead and very carefully
Target he needs to go ahead and very
carefully Target what his next season of
life looks like what his next career is
going to be get in the kinkola materials
take the get clear assessment on Ken's
stuff get the proximity principle book
paycheck to purpose book start looking
at the resume templates and all that and
then go go ahead and start looking for
and Landing the new job it's not unusual
at all he has a pretty good idea
when these going to be cut loose I mean
within a month or two yeah and so and as
you get closer and closer it's going to
get dialed in more and more and more and
you can dial in the job
um maybe you're just practicing a little
bit early but go ahead and practice go
ahead and go out go out there and do the
interviews get the job talk about you
know I'm not exactly sure when I'm going
to be released but when I am released
this is where I want to be and if they
need you to start this week well you
can't start this week I'm not eligible
for that position but
he needs to go get the next job lined up
and I'm a little confused how you
graduate from college and you make 16
dollars I'm wondering the same you can
make 18 stocking shelves at Target
yeah
what in the world she needs to get her
income up yeah you're you're a step away
from Wendy's right there and I think
that I think you're stuck behind Wendy's
yeah your step away but it's behind yeah
that's true oh man I don't know what
yeah I'm not sure what your degree is in
or what your career field is but you've
got some work to do on your income
absolutely but but trade is Right
temporarily we're in the middle of a
bunch of transition a bunch of storms
let's just pile up cash a big old pile
like you were like you were paying
aggressively on debt that's aggressively
pile the cash and then the day that he
lands the new position or the day that
the uncertainty around all of this goes
away uh then you take that money you
throw it at your debt snowball down to
one thousand dollars and you start
working your baby steps straight up
you're exactly right that's right
exactly how I would approach this all
right Sam is in Dayton Ohio Hi Sam
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for having me sure what's a
question I have a question about using
an HSA for investment versus uh medical
costs
so I recently had a hand injury and um I
met my deductible and whatnot and I was
wondering if I should pay myself back
for those expenses uh from the HSA that
I'm I've been building or just continue
to rebuild my emergency fund with the
income that I have how much money
uh five thousand dollars
what's your income
uh about ninety thousand
you have any debt
no other than my house good way to go uh
is this over or is this gonna be ongoing
Medical
it's over
okay
um and you've already cash flowed it
yeah to this point it would be
replenishing my emergency fund with
you'd be reimbursing yourself from the
HSA to replenish your your three to six
months you know I'm gonna go ahead and
just put the money into the uh
just leave it I'm going to recoup in
cash flow I'm going to leave it in the
HSA you don't have to have it the beauty
of the HSA is two things one a large
lump sum you cannot cash flow and it
allows you to uh to cover it obviously
the health savings account and the
second thing is it's tax free so if
you've got a chronic situation like I've
got a friend that's got Crohn's and so
he's got chronic he's got bills and
bills and bills he's always got bills
going and and so basically he gets all
of his health care tax-free because he
pays all the bills out of the HSA which
is a tax-free account tax deductible
account and so where you've got a
chronic situation that's why I ask if
this is ongoing then it makes a lot of
sense or if it's super large now I
transpo you know that uh the opposite
way of looking at that is uh what I have
done with my HSA is I've never touched
it
yeah and I think I've got
I may have 400 Grand in there now
I just I've loaded it every year yeah
it's like another retirement account
that's right and I just put it in mutual
funds and so but we've been inordinately
healthy at the Ramsey house knock on
wood yeah so we haven't had any big
events
um and the events that we did have uh
small to medium or whatever they were we
just wrote a check for them and so we've
just treated it as an investment account
for that reason so we know that for the
people listening you wouldn't invest
your money that the money that's sitting
in your HSA you wouldn't actually invest
it obviously until you're in baby step
four but Dave what at what amount let's
say you're in baby step four at what
amount in your HSA would you then start
investing it into the the funds they
have there in the mutual funds yeah uh
when you know you're going to be living
it alone when you're in a strong enough
financial condition you're going to be
living it alone and so for most people
that's probably they've got an extra 20
grand in there or something like that
and uh like we've got a company called
Health Equity that we've endorsed and
that we use here instead of our company
and they they are they allow us to take
the HSA and put it into mutual funds of
our choice and so 100 of mine because I
just don't need it and so I'm using it
as yet another way to keep the taxes off
of that small amount of money every year
and once you hit a certain age you can
access that as though it were a normal
retirement no longer has to be used for
actual health health purchases so that's
a great thing about it it's a wonderful
vehicle love that exactly James is in
Huntsville hi James welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help
hey so I'm 23
um and I have actually purchased a house
the beginning of this year
um my issue now is I am at risk of a
foreclosure on my house
um just kind of needed some guidance I'm
kind of new to your plan and seeing
um what maybe I can do to help myself
out how many payments behind are you
I am four payments behind okay what kind
of loan FHA V A or conventional uh is a
FHA okay
um why are you behind
um so I work in healthcare and I've
actually had coveted three times within
the last
um in the last six months as well as
some family things that kind of got me
behind on on work I work 24-hour shifts
so if I miss one shift I miss
um almost half of my check
okay uh coveted three times is 12 or 14
days 15 days
correct that does not put you four house
payments behind
there's another problem at work here
the family stuff is much bigger than the
coveted stuff
okay is that right uh that there were
several days that I missed due to due to
lost family members and and things such
as that yes yeah all right tell you what
we're going into a commercial break I
don't want to give you a short answer on
your home being foreclosed answer it's
too important we'll help you when we
come back you hang on with us okay this
is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today we're
talking with James and Huntsville he's
23. he's four payments behind on an FHA
loan trying to figure out what to do
with foreclosure bearing down on him
that's due to he's in health care having
had coveted a couple three times and
having had some family issues some
losses in the family that have cost them
some work hours as well and uh so forth
that's about how much we how far we got
into the call is that a fair summary of
what you told me so far sir
yes sir okay how much your house payment
uh my house payment is one thousand
fifty two dollars a month okay how many
bedrooms
uh it is a three bedroom two bath how
many roommates
I have no roommates okay um I did have
one
um so getting into that um if I'm if
that's okay
um I had some issues with the house that
were not found in the inspection and
um they were the roommates were not
comfortable with with those issues until
I got those fixed what is that
um so the insulation in the Attic causes
several air leaks um around so the the
heating and cooling is an issue
um there were some electrical issues
with power surging
um as well as uh
the house was built in 1985.
okay
um all right cool do you have any idea
what the house is worth today have you
talked to a real estate agent
the house is worth around 1 195.
uh that was I did try to sell the house
early early in the year because I
realized that I got into a situation
um and that's what it was appraised at
through their through their appraisers
okay and what do you owe on it
oh 180. okay cool all right good
um so what I would do number one is I'd
contact a real estate agent at
ramseysolutions.com under ELP our Ramsey
trusted real estate agent talked to a
couple of different ones uh tell them to
get over there and get it listed uh this
week so that it's on the on on the
market as soon as the first of the year
hits okay we want to get that get that
part moving
um and what do you make yeah
I make uh 48.5 a year what do you do
I work in uh the Emergency Medical
Services
you're an EMT
that's correct
James how long have you had this house
since the beginning of the year okay
okay okay yeah all right uh so you're
working what kind of shifts it is an EMT
um so right now our set shifts are 24 on
72 off
um trying to get in ahead of this and
get it fixed I'm working 24 on 24 off
and then 24 back on
okay so you're able to pick up extra
hours in other words yes and that raises
your 48 considerable
okay all right so 24 on 24 off
correct okay
all right but the 24 on is you're at the
firehouse and you may or may not be
awake you may or may not I mean you have
to be ready to make a call if the call
comes in but you can sleep correct
that's correct yeah you're not up 24
hours just for those of you listening
all right
um so you're working like a fireman type
uh with the fireman a type of a shift
okay uh
is there any scenario where he can yeah
you can work so when you're off work go
ahead and pick up some side stuff
immediately hustle and grind
um and you you've you've got the right
antidote which the antidotes work and
create as much money as you can create
um as fast as you can create it and
start throwing it at this here's the
thing
uh there's a couple things that give you
some peace number one with an FHA loan
there is zero chance they are going to
foreclose before you are six to seven
payments behind
so if you don't do squat which you're
not going to do but if you do nothing
you got two months
that that's great okay number one number
two if they do foreclose HUD the
Department of Housing Urban Development
does not chase a deficit
on this so if they take the house back
and lose money they do not come after
you your credit will be messed up but
you don't have a deficit they're not
going to come after you
okay so these are like our worst case
scenarios that are not going to happen
understood what's going to happen is
you're going to go make a bunch of money
and you're going to get current
yes definitely um
with this is
um if is a quick sale something that I I
should look into a short sale a short
sale you don't need a short sale because
you've got a little bit of equity
someone will pick this up for what's
owed on it in this current market
okay because you got a cheap house cheap
houses are hard to come by
understood there's not a lot of 185 000
houses in Huntsville Alabama it's just
that's a good that's a that's a sweet
price point it should sell it should
sell with a good realtor you may have to
you may have to do some extra cleanup
you may have to do some odds and ends
things but you need to get this thing on
the market and get it going it is not a
blessing to you
right and that's what I realized
whenever I after I got into the house
and started looking at everything and
and started figuring out what needed to
be done with the house
okay the the last thing is this there's
a process called a forbearance
and get with a Ramsay coach on our
website and they can help you work a
forbearance a forbearance is where they
negotiate with the mortgage company
giving them good reason to believe that
you can get caught up and the good
reason is your new budget based on all
the work you are doing and the work
you're getting ready to do that you're
not even doing yet all the income you're
creating because you're going to go
create seventy eighty thousand dollars
worth of income working uh 70 80 hours a
week right now your 23 you can do that
now what a forbearance is you're going
to pay like a payment and a half
for eight months
okay and that'll bring you current and
that also stops a foreclosure as long as
you get in the forbearance and you stick
to it so you can get with Ramsay coach
set up a forbearance of a payment and a
half and nothing precludes you from
prepaying that and stopping the
forbearance early because you made
enough money just to quote get current
understood but a payment and a half on
four payments behind will get you there
in eight months you see how I'm doing
that
correct so you're not going to get
foreclosed on we're gonna put the house
up for sale we're gonna put it on a
forbearance and you're going to work
like a freaking maniac and create money
like you've never created before in your
life no excuses nothing else to do you
don't get to spend money on anything but
food lights water and house payments
that's it you don't get to do nothing
gas to get to work that's all you just
bear freaking bones so hold on James
I've been where you are I've been scared
like you are I know how it feels we're
going to help you I'll have Austin pick
up and we'll hook you up with one of our
Ramsay coaches and help you with that
forbearance part you are going to get in
touch with an ELP on the website and you
are going to pick up yet another side
job in addition to your overtime
that's good that's a tough situation but
those things that you explain those
those are good things to know about the
the 67 payments behind before they'll
come after you again it's making sure
that you understand all the facts it's
not just a bunch of unknowns floating
around in your head creating chaos you
know I feel like you gave him some real
it's probably fair to let folks know I
mean I used to buy foreclosures for a
living and I've done this foreclosure
forbearances with people for 30 years
now and after that so here's the thing
HUD the FHA is the Government Federal
Government Federal housing
Administration guarantees this loan for
we'll say Countrywide okay so they have
regulations on Countrywide to keep
Countrywide from just instantly
foreclosing because if they instantly
when they foreclose FHA gets the house
back in Countrywide gets all their money
so they don't want Country-Wide just
pulling the rug on everybody I see so
they've got in order for Country-Wide
for their guarantee to get all their
money the federal guarantee the FHA
guarantee to get all their money they
have to abide by Hud's regulations on a
foreclosure scenario and have to take
certain steps there's like I don't know
there used to be 25 steps 26 steps or
whatever and it takes six months for
them to do that I see so they the
mortgage company would lose their FHA
guarantee against loss on the loan if
they don't follow those steps and those
steps take six months yeah so it's not
unusual to find an FHA that's 12 months
behind wow before it's foreclosed on but
you never see one under six months ever
the Millennium is a long long time I've
never seen one the more you know that's
where that came from so that that is not
to abuse the system but that's to give
you peace while you make the turnaround
right that's how this works this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Luke 2 8-11
and there were shepherds living out in
the fields nearby
keeping watch over their flocks at night
an angel of the Lord appeared to them
and the glory of the Lord Shone around
them and they were terrified
but the angel said to them do not be
afraid
I bring you good news
that will cause great joy for all the
people
today
in the town of David a savior has been
born to you
he is the messiah
the Lord
Billy Graham said the very purpose of
Christ coming into the world was that he
might offer up his life as a sacrifice
for the sins of men he came to die
this is the heart
of Christmas God gave
is only begotten son Jade warshaw Ramsay
personality is my co-host today Merry
Christmas to you thank you for being
with us America Nathan is next Nathan is
in Minnesota hi Nathan welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave hey Jade welcome to the show
Merry Christmas to you guys Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas to you what's
up
yes thank you
um I had a couple questions regarding
investing
um I'm about to start baby step four
and I'm wondering first question what
your thoughts on REITs are
and then the second question is I know
you say not to invest in single stocks
however what have you ever done any
research on investing in several stocks
for a dividend portfolio
with uh you know at least 10 percent
rates per turn over 10 years sure just
looking at drips yeah uh the thing is it
that all of those things are fine REITs
and drips are fine uh for your portfolio
once you hit baby step seven
and you're maxing out your retirement
but for your retirement accounts
themselves you're the most efficient
growth and the best growth is going to
be just straight up the four types of
mutual funds we talk about the math I'll
show you that if you look at the track
records growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international the
REITs have really come on in the last I
don't know decade maybe even 15 years uh
and are they are a legitimate way to get
some money in real estate now you can
find REITs with good track records
that'll be as good as a growth stock
mutual fund up in the 10 12 maybe even
13 range on a good long track record
well-run long track record so you know
you can find something you're
comfortable with there for sure and
drips drips a little more difficult to
pull off that put that portfolio
management few people do it well uh it's
uh it's academically theoretically
possible it's a pain in the butt to
actually pull it off and uh and a lot of
people talk about it more than they
actually do it among the millionaires
that I talk to okay
so but but REITs I'm fine with but I
wouldn't use a read in your in your 401k
I'll just fill up that with regular
mutual funds like we're talking about
but after you get to baby step seven and
you've got some extra money to invest
and you don't want to be a landlord a
read is okay and if you want to do some
trips that's fine if you want to do some
single stocks it's okay I just tell
people don't the people get all jacked
up about the sexiness of buying and
selling stocks and the track record is
is that people don't make much money
doing it the average investor buying and
selling on his own account makes about a
seven percent rate of return on single
stocks where the mutual where the market
is averaged 11 to 12. so you know that's
the reason I don't do it but I tell
folks if you want to fool around with it
sometimes people enjoy it almost as a
hobby yeah a maximum of 10 of your net
worth and that's really at baby step
seven and Beyond is what I would do
there
so thanks for calling in brother
appreciate you all right Mark is in
Santa Barbara hey Mark welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave uh so Merry Christmas by the
way um my brother told me about uh your
show and it kind of humidifier to my
butt to become debt free good
um
uh and so I think I might be on baby
step two but I might have accidentally
started baby step three did you pay off
for all your debts
60
000 in student loans right now okay
um
and but I've also got some Investments
about a little over a hundred thousand
Investments and I'm wondering if I
should in retirement account or open
Investments
uh retirement account
um Company stock that uh the company's
offered me how much Company stock have
you got in dollars
forty one thousand good how much
non-retirement money do you have other
than that
non-retirement other than that there's 7
000 in an HSA and about 5 000 and just
other things uh okay all right so you
got sixty thousand dollars in debt and
we've got forty six thousand dollars to
throw at it good that reduces it a lot
what's your income
it's uh a hundred and it'll be 152
000 uh come next year it's certainly
more than I deserve I I just want to
check uh Mark did you hear what what
Dave's telling you to do right there
he's telling you to liquidate that that
company stock and put it onto your debt
yeah
I didn't quite catch that okay that's
what we're telling you to do yeah we
don't want to touch the the retirement
accounts but the the company stock where
you said you had about 41k there and
then you said you had some other money
we want you to liquidate that we want
you to sell it off because that company
stock it's it's it's in one company if
and if anything happens that to that
company you're going to lose that money
so that's not typically the way that we
would tell you that's never the way we
would tell you to invest so you can go
ahead and liquidate that you can throw
it towards your debt and if you're still
currently investing we would tell you to
actually pause your investing for the
time being and take that money and add
it to your baby step two part of your
debt snowball does that make sense
yeah it that it kind of blows my mind
because I was ready to start hustling I
know you were I know you can go ahead
and start hustling too yeah do that too
yeah go and make some here's the thing
here's the thing what we've discovered
is that the reason people don't win with
money is they try to do seven things at
once and they get none of them done
which is what you've been doing you're
buying single stocks you're putting
money in your mutual funds you're
working on your debt and you're thinking
about taking an extra job and nothing's
moving
instead I just punched this thing in the
face a minute ago
I mean the boxer is laid out on the mat
I just knocked him down
and you're gonna go for the next time he
gets up you're gonna finish him off
total freaking focus on one goal at a
time first goal no debt but your house
we're getting rid of that sixty thousand
second goal an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses now we're
ready to invest because you don't have
any payments in the world you make 150
000 you're a stud man you're ready to go
now
heck yeah that makes a lot of sense okay
the good news is you're on fire about
your situation you're on fire about
doing the best that you possibly can
with your money we're just trying to
make sure that you do it in the in the
smartest most effective way hey man I'm
gonna send you a copy of this little
quick read we just did called the
momentum theorem
focused intensity over time multiplied
by God creates Unstoppable momentum and
that's exactly what we're talking about
here I'll also send you a copy of the
book The Total Money Maker to show you
how to work this plan Merry Christmas to
you thanks for calling in so Jay that's
the uh the difference in the Ramsey Way
is that we have figured out the math
doesn't work
when you only do math well yeah we know
that money is not just about math and in
a lot of ways it's more about your mind
it's Behavior Behavior it's your
behavior your character your
relationships your focus or your lack of
it
and it's amazing that when people start
the the number of times for instance if
someone does a debt free scream and
their income has gone up dramatically
during the two or three or four years
they've been getting out of debt
it's because they now had a reason for
it too that's true they've got all of
these things in their life they were
just kind of out running out there on
mediocrity all of a sudden they're
striving for excellence to cause that
one thing to happen and it's all pointed
at that one thing but that Rising tide
raises every part of their life their
relationships get better yep their their
career accelerates their income
accelerates and as they're trying to hit
this One Singular focused goal of
clearing the debt and then later on we
take that same exact power and point it
at wealth building and that's why we end
up with all these baby steps
millionaires focused intensity over time
that's it multiplied by God equals
Unstoppable momentum the momentum
theorem that's that little book I was
just talking about puts a sour into
books way to go Austin Ben James sack
and Andrew Merry Christmas booth dudes
you guys do a great job Zach great job
in there man be careful on the road
absolutely
hey we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]